the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so okay so remember last time we learned
about the cross product of vectors in
space
so remember of a definition of cross
product is in terms of this determinant
I had J hat K hat and then the
components of a a 1 a 2 a 3 and then the
components of B and this is not an
actual determinant because these are not
numbers but it's a symbolic notation to
remember what the actual formula is the
actual formula is obtained by expanding
the determinant so we have actually this
smaller determinant a2 a3 b2 b3 times I
had minus determinant of a1 a3 b1 b3
times J hat plus determinant of a1 a2 b1
b2 times K hat and we also saw a more
geometric definition of the cross
product so we've learned that the length
of the cross product is equal to the
area of the parallelogram with sides a
and b
we've also learned that the direction of
the cross product is given by taking the
junction that's perpendicular to a and B
so in fact if I draw a and B in a plane
return in a plane together then the
cross product should go in the direction
that's perpendicular to that plane now
there's two different possible
directions that are perpendicular to a
plane and to decide which one it is we
use the right hand rule which says if
you extend your right hand in the
direction of vector a then curve your
fingers in the direction of B then your
firm will go in the direction of the
cross product okay so one thing I didn't
quite get to say last time is that there
are some funny manipulation rules
what are we allowed to do or not do with
cross products so let me tell you right
away the most surprising one may be if
you've never seen it before
it's that equals B and B Class A are not
the same thing why are we not the same
thing well one way to see it is to think
geometrically sure the parallelogram
still has the same area and it's still
in the same plane so it still
perpendicular to the same plane but what
happens is if you try to apply the
right-hand rule that exchanging the
holes of a and B then you will either
enjoy yourself or you will end up
pointing in the opposite direction okay
so in fact because a and equals B are
opposite of each other and you can check
that on the formula because see for
example the I component is a2 b3 minus
a3 b2 if you swept the holes of a and B
you will also have to change the signs
okay so that's a slightly surprising
thing
but you'll see one easily adjust to it
it just means resist the temptation to
marginal a B equals B a whenever you do
that put a minus sign now in particular
well what happens if I do a cross a well
I will get zero and you know there's
many ways to see that when it's use the
formula also you can say just that you
know the parallelogram form by a and a
is completely flat and it has a is 0 so
that's the zero vector okay
so hopefully you get practice with cross
products and computing them in
recitation yesterday let me just point
out one important application of cross
product that maybe you haven't seen yet
so let's say that I'm given three points
in space and I want to find the equation
of the plane that contains them so say I
have P 1 P 2 P 3 3 points in space
well the datum in a plane I mean at
least if they are not aligned and we
would like to find the equation of the
plane that we determine so that means
let's say that we have a point P in
space with coordinates XYZ well the
equation of the plane let's say the
plane containing P 1 P 2 and P 3 that so
that means find a condition we need to
find a condition on the coordinates XYZ
telling us whether P is in the plane or
not
okay so we have several ways of doing
that for example one thing we could do
let me just back try to determinants
that we saw last time so one way to
think about it is to consider this
vectors P 1 P 2 P 1 P 3 and P 1 P ok so
the question of whether they are all in
the same plane is the same as asking
ourselves whether the parallelepiped
that we form is actually completely
flattened right if I try to form a
parallelepiped with these three sides
well if P is not in the plane then it
will have some volume but if P is in the
plane that means that it's actually
completely squished
so
one possible answer one way to think of
the equation of the plane should be that
the determinant of these vectors should
be zero determinant of P 1 P 2 P 1 P 3
and if you let me do it in a different
order doesn't really matter but so one
possible way to express the condition
that P is in the plane is to say that
the determinant of these three vectors
has to be zero and if I'm given
coordinates for these points and I'm not
giving you numbers but if I gave you
numbers then you would be able to plug
these numbers in so you could compute
these two vectors explicitly you would
have numbers here but here of course
this would depend on x y&z so when you
compute the determinant you get a
formula that involves XY and Z and you
will find that this condition and XYZ
that's the equation of the plane okay so
we're going to see more about that
pretty soon now let me tell you about
the slightly faster way of doing it so
it's not much faster it's pretty much
the same calculation but it's maybe more
enlightening oh let me actually show you
a nice color picture that I prepared for
this ok so right so one thing that's on
this picture that I haven't drawn there
is the normal vector to the plane so why
is that well let's say that we know how
to find a vector that's perpendicular to
our plane then what does it mean for the
point P to be in the plane well it means
that the direction set from P 1 to P has
to be perpendicular to this vector n ok
so here's another solution
so P is in the plane only when well
exactly when the vector P 1p is
perpendicular to n where n is some
vector that's perpendicular to the plane
so that's called a nomal vector not that
the others are abnormal but okay so how
do we rephrase this condition well we've
learned how to detect whether two
vectors are perpendicular to each other
using dot product okay dot product
that's the first lecture so these two
vectors are perpendicular exactly when
their dot product is zero okay and so
now
concretely well if we have a point P 1
given to us and say we have been able to
compute the vector n then well when we
actually compute what happens here we
will have the coordinates XYZ of the
point P and we'll get some condition on
X Y Z that will be the equation of a
plane again now why are these things the
same well if I can tell you that I
should tell you how can we find a normal
vector but maybe you are already
starting to see what the method should
be because we know how to find vectors
perpendicular to two given vectors right
so we know two vectors in that plane for
example p1p2 and p1p3 actually I could
have used you know another permutation
of the points but let's use these so if
I don't find the vector that's
perpendicular to both p1p2 and p1p3 at
the same time all I have to do is take
the cross product so how do we find this
vector that's perpendicular to the plane
well the answer is we can just take the
cross product P 1 P 2 because P 1 P 3
I should say well you know say that's
actually YouTube the point in a
different order you did p1 p3 equals p1
p2 you'd get of course the opposite
vector that is fine any plane has
actually infinitely many normal vectors
you can just you know multiply the
normal vector by any constant you will
still get a normal vector that's
absolutely fine so that's going to be
one of the main uses of dot product see
when we know two vectors in a plane it
lets us find the normal vector to the
plane and that is what we need to find
the equation now why is that the same as
the answer over there well the condition
that we have is that P 1 P dot n should
be 0 and we said n is actually P 1 P 2
cos P 1 P 3 so this is what we want to
be zero now if you remember stuff from a
long time ago I mean that was Friday
when we've introduced this thing and
called it the triple product ok and what
we've seen is that the triple product is
the same thing as the determinant so in
fact these two ways of thinking one
saying that the box formed by these
three vectors should be flat and have
volume 0 and the other one's saying that
we can find a normal vector and then
express the condition that a vector is
in the plane if it's perpendicular to
the normal vector they are actually
giving us the same formula in the end
okay any quick questions before we move
on yes so these two quantities P 1 P dot
cross product of a determinant of the
three vectors they're always equal to
each other okay they're always the same
and now if a point is not in the plane
then the numerical value will be nonzero
if P is in the plane it will be zero
okay let's move on and talk a bit about
matrices so probably some of you have
seen about matrices a little bit in high
school but certainly not all of you and
so anyway let me just introduce you to a
little bit about matrices just enough
for what we'll need later in this class
I should say if you want to know
everything about the secret life of
matrices when you should take 1806
Sunday so okay so what's going to be our
motivation for matrices well in life a
lot of things are related by linear
formulas and even if they are not mean
so maybe sometimes you can approximate
them by linear formulas so often we have
linear relations between variables
and for example well if we if we do a
change of coordinate systems so for
example you know say that we're in space
well and we have a point
so it's coordinates might be let me call
them x1 x2 x3 in my initial coordinate
system but then maybe I need to actually
switch to different coordinates to
better solve my problem because it's
more adapted to other things I will do
in my problem and so I have other
coordinate axes and then in these new
coordinates well it will have actually
different coordinates let me call them
say u1 u2 u3 and when the relation
between the old and the new coordinates
is going to be by linear formulas I mean
especially if I choose the same origin
otherwise there might be constant terms
which I will not insist on so let me
just give an example for example maybe I
don't know let's say for example u 1
could be twice X 1 plus 3 times X 2 plus
3 times X way
you two might be 2 times X 1 plus 4
times X 2 plus 5 times X 3 u 3 might be
X 1 plus X 2 plus 2 is X 3 do not ask me
where these numbers come from I just
made them up okay that's just an example
of what might happen so plug you know
put here your favorite numbers if you
want okay so now
in order to express this kind of linear
relation we can use matrices so a matrix
is just a table with numbers in it and
so we can reformulate this in terms of
matrix multiplication our matrix product
okay so instead of writing this I will
write that the matrix 2 3 3 2 4 5 1 1 2
times the vector X 1 X 2 X 3 is equal to
u 1 u 2 u 3 okay so hopefully you see
that where's the same information
content on both sides I just need to
explain to you what this way of
multiplying tables of numbers means well
what it means is really that you know
we'll take exactly these quantities but
let me just say that not symbolically so
maybe this matrix we could call a you
know and this we could call X and this
we could call capital you don't X then
we'll say a times X equals U which is a
lot shorter than that of course I need
to tell you what a X and u are in terms
of their entries for you to get the
formula but it's convenient notation so
what does it mean to do a matrix product
so the end phase in product
so it should say so in the matrix
product obtained by doing the dot
product so let's say we're doing the
product a X so we do a dot product
between the rows dot product between the
rows of a and the columns of X so maybe
I should say here a is a three by three
matrix that just means there's you know
three rows and three columns and X is a
column vector which we can think of as a
3 by 1 matrix it has three rows and only
one column ok so now what can we do well
I said we're going to do the dot product
between Ohio of a 2 3 3 and the column
of X X 1 X 2 X 3 well that dot product
will be 2 times X 1 plus 3 times X 2
plus 3 times X 3 it's exactly what we
want to set u 1 equal to let's do the
second one I take the second row of a 2
4 5 and I do the dot product with X 1 X
2 X 3 I will get 2 times X 1 plus 4
times X 2 plus 5 times X 3 which is this
thing and same with the third one 1
times X 1 plus 1 times X 2 plus 2 times
X 3 okay so that's matrix multiplication
so again I mean let me maybe
we stayed with modern hourly so if I
want to find the nth phase of a product
of two matrices a and B so I'm saying
matrices but they could be of course
vectors are now a special case of
matrices just by taking a matrix of
width one ok so if I have my matrix a
and I have my matrix B and then I will
get the product a B well let's say for
example that a you know this works in
any sizes so let's say that a is a 4 so
your 3 by 4 matrix so it has three rows
four columns and here I'm not going to
give you the values because I'm not
going to compute everything it would
take you know the last of a lecture so
and let's say that B is maybe size 4 by
2 so it has two columns and four holes
and let's say for example that we have
the second column is 0 for a 0 2 so a
times B I claim will have well the
entries should be the dot products
between visuals and these columns here
we have two columns here we have three
holes so we should get you know three
times two different possibilities and so
the answer will have size 3 by 2 okay
and well we cannot compute most of them
because I didn't give you numbers but
one of them we can compute we can
compute the one that goes here namely
this one in the second column so I
select the second column of B and in the
first hole so I take the first row of a
and I find well 1 times 0 0 2 times 3 6
plus 0 plus 8 should make 14 so this
entry here is 14 okay so
in fact let me tell you about another
way to set it up so that you remember
more easily how you know what goes where
so one way that you can set it up is you
can put a here you can put B up here and
then you will get the answer here and if
you want to find what goes in a given
slot here then you just look to its left
and you look above it and you do the dot
product between these guys okay so
that's I think an easy way to remember
you know first of all it tells you what
the size of the answer will be the size
will be well what fits nicely in this
box should have the same weight as be in
the same height as a and second it tells
you which dot product to compute for
each position okay so you just look at
what's to the left and what's above the
given position now there's a catch can
we multiply anything by anything well no
okay I mean I wouldn't ask the question
otherwise but but anyway C to be able to
do this dot product we need to have the
same number of entries here and here
otherwise we can't say take this times
that Plus this times that and so on if
we run out of space on one of them
before V over so the condition and it's
kind of important so let me write it in
red is that the width of a must equal
the height of B
okay so it's a bit cluttered ultimate
hopefully you can still see what I'm
writing so okay but now we know how to
multiply matrices
so what does it mean to multiply
matrices I mean of course we've seen you
know in this example that we can use the
matrix to tell us how to transform from
X's to use and that's an example of
multiplication but now let's say that we
have two matrices like that telling us
how to transform from something to
something else what does it mean to
multiply them so I claim is that so I
claim that the product a B represents
doing first the transformation B then
transformation a so that's a slightly
counterintuitive thing because we're
used to fighting things from left to
right unfortunately with matrices the
way they're done you multiply five I
mean you multiply things from right to
left if you think about it you know when
you write say you have two functions F
and G you write F of G of X 20 means you
apply first G then F so it works the
same way as well
okay so why what why is this well if I
write a B times X where X is some vector
that I want to transform it's the same
as a times B X okay so this property is
called associativity and it's a good
property of well-behaved products not of
cross product by the way but so matrix
product is associative that means we can
actually think of a product a B X and
multiply them in whichever order we want
we can start with B X so we can start
with a B so now BX means we apply the
transformation B to X and then
multiplying by a means we apply the
transformation a so we first apply B
then we apply a but
the same as applying ad all at once okay
so another note of warning
is that a B and BA are not the same
thing at all well I mean you probably
see that already from this
interpretation it's not the same thing -
you know convert arranges to bananas
when two cards or vice versa on the
other hand well I mean actually even
worse this thing might not even be well
defined because you know if height of
sorry the width of a equals the height
of B we can do this product but we don't
necessarily I mean it's not clear that
the width of B will equal the height of
a width of a which is what we would need
for that one okay so you know the size
condition to be able to do the product
might not make sense actually maybe one
of them doesn't even make sense even if
they both make sense they're usually
completely different things okay
the next thing I need to tell you is
something called the identity matrix
well the identity matrix is the matrix
that does nothing okay so what does it
mean to do nothing I don't mean the
matrix 0 the matrix 0 would take X and
would always give you back 0 that's not
very interesting transformation what I
mean is the guy that takes X and gives
you X again so it satisfies you know
property I so it's called I and it has a
property that I x equals x for all X so
it's the transformation from something
to itself it's the obvious
transformation called the identity
transformation so how do we write that
as a matrix well so actually there's an
identity for each size you know because
of course depending on whether X has to
enter phase of 10 entries the matrix I
need to have a different size
so for example the identity matrix of
size 3 by 3 has entries one one one on
the diagonal and zeros everywhere else
ok let's check if we multiply this with
a vector well maybe I should do that on
a separate board but so start thinking
about it what happens when I multiply
this with a vector X
okay so let's say I multiply the matrix
I with a vector X 1 X 2 X 3 well what
will be the first entry it will be the
dot product between 1 0 0 and X 1 X 2 X
3 if you want this vector is I had okay
so if you do the dot product with I hat
you will get the X component you will
get the first component that will be X 1
1 times X 1 plus 0 0 similarly here if I
do the dot product I get 0 plus X 2 plus
0 I get X 2 and here I get X 3 okay it
works same thing if I put here a matrix
I will get back the same matrix now of
course okay so in general the identity
matrix in size n by n so it's an N by n
thing with ones on the diagonal and
zeros everywhere else okay you just put
one at every diagonal position and 0
elsewhere and then you can see if you
multiply that by your vector you will
get the same vector back ok
oh okay let me give you another example
of a matrix let's say that in the plane
we look at the transformation that does
rotation by 90 degrees let's say
counterclockwise so I claim that this is
given by the matrix 0 1 minus 1 0 so
let's try to see why that is the case
well if I do our times I had so if I
apply that to the first vector I had so
that means I hat will be 1 0 this
product well here you will get 0 and
then you will get 1 to get J hat okay so
this thing sends I had 2 J hat
what about J hat well you get negative 1
and then you get 0 so that's - I hat so
J is sent to what here and in general if
you apply it to a vector with
coordinates X Y with components X Y then
you will get back - Y X which is a
formula we've seen for rotating a vector
by 90 degrees so it seems to do what we
want by the way I should point out so
the columns in this matrix we present
what happens to each basis vector to the
vectors I and J see what I mean this guy
here is exactly what we get when we
multiply R by I and when when we
multiply our by J we get this guy here
so what's interesting about this matrix
well we can do computations with
matrices in ways that are easier than
writing coordinate change formulas for
example if you compute R squared so if
you multiply R with itself well I let
you do it as an exercise but you will
find that you get minus 1 minus 1 0 0 so
that's minus the identity matrix
why is that well if I rotate something
by 90 degrees and then I rotate by 90
degrees again then I will rotate by 180
degrees that means I will actually just
go to the opposite point around the
origin so I will take X y2 minus X minus
y ok and if I applied our four times out
of the four would be identity okay
questions yes
ah that's a very good question so how
did I come up with this R well secretly
I worked pretty hard to find what are
the entries that would tell me how to
rotate something by 90 degrees
counterclockwise so remember I mean I
should have said what we saw I think
last time or the first lecture is that
to rotate a vector by 90 degrees we
should change X Y 2 minus y X okay and
so now I'm trying to express work on
this transformation as a matrix and if
you work out you know how this guy's so
maybe you want to call this guy's U and
V and if you write U equals 0 X minus 1
y 0 X minus 1 1 and then V equals 1 X
plus 0 y 1 x plus 0 Y ok so that's how I
would find it here actually I just gave
it to you
you know ready-made so you didn't really
see how how I found it but you will see
more about rotations on the problem on
the problem set there's so you're going
to see more about these things ok so
next I need to tell you how to invert
matrices so what's the point of matrices
it's that it gives us a nice way to
think about these changes of variables
and in particular if we know how to
express you in terms of X maybe we'd
like to
know how to express X in terms of you
well we can do that because we've
learned how to solve linear systems like
this okay so in principle we could start
working substituting and so on to find
formulas for the X 1 X 2 X 3 as
functions of U 1 u 2 y 8 u 3 and the
relation will be again a linear relation
it will again be given by your matrix
well what's that matrix it's the inverse
transformation so it's the inverse of
the matrix a so we are going to learn
how to find the inverse of a matrix
directly okay
so the inverse of a by definition is a
matrix M with the property that if I
multiply a by M then I get identity and
if I multiply M by a I also get identity
if the two properties are equivalent so
that means you know if I apply first for
transformation a when the transformation
M actually I undo the transformation a
and vice-versa these two transformations
are the opposite of each other well I
should say the inverse of each other
okay so for this to make sense
we need a must be a square matrix okay
so it must have size and by n can be any
size but it must be the same number of
holes as columns and it's a general fact
that I mean you will see more in detail
in linear algebra if you take it so
let's just admit that so so the matrix M
we will denote by a inverse like this
okay and then what is it good for well
for example the solution to a linear
system so what's a linear system in our
new language it's a matrix times some
unknown vector x equals some known
vector B well how do we solve that we
just compute x equals a inverse B why
does that work how do I get from here to
here let's be careful
okay well I'm going to reuse this matrix
but I'm going to erase it nonetheless
and just rewrite it
so I'm saying if ax equals B then let's
multiply both sides by a inverse a
inverse times ax is a inverse B and then
well a inverse times a is identity so I
get x equals a inverse B that's how I
solved my system of equations so if you
have a calculator that can invert
matrices when you can solve linear
systems very quickly now we should still
learn how to compute these things yes
how do I know that aim in this will be
on the left of B and not after it well
it's exactly in this derivation so if
you're ever not sure then just reproduce
with calculation C I mean to get from
here to here what I did is I multiplied
things on the left by a inverse and then
these guys simplify if I had put a
inverse on the right I will have a XA
inverse which might not make sense and
even if it makes sense it doesn't
simplify so I mean the basic hole is you
know you have to multiply by inverse on
the left so that it cancels with this a
that's on the left that's going so and
you know in our usual way of dealing
with matrices where the vectors are
column vectors I mean interesting to
remember that if you have a square
matrix times a column vector I mean the
product that makes sense is with the
matrix on the left the vector on the
right the other one just doesn't work
it's not sized you cannot take x times a
if a and X you know if a is a square
matrix and X is a column vector this
product makes sense the other one
doesn't make sense it's not the right
size
okay so what we need to do is to learn
how to invert a matrix and it's useful
to know first for your general knowledge
and second because actually it's it's
actually useful later for things we'll
see in this class so in particular on
the exam you will need to know how to
invert a matrix by hand so I should say
this formula is actually good for small
matrices you know 3 by 3 4 by 4 it's not
good at all if you have a matrix of size
of thousand by a thousand so in computer
software actually for small matrices we
do this for larger matrices we use other
algorithms but let's just see how we do
it
so I'm going to do it okay so first of
all I will give you a final answer
and of course for that I will need to
explain what the answer means so we'll
have to compute something called the
adjoint matrix and they will tell you
how to do that and then we'll divide by
the determinant of a so how do we get to
the adjoint matrix so let's go for the
steps on a 3x3 example the steps are the
same no matter what the size is but
let's do 3 by 3 so let's say that I'm
giving you the matrix a well let's say
it's the same as earlier the one that I
erased
so that was one relating our axes and
I'll use
so the first thing I want to do is find
what's called the menos so what's a
minor well it's a slightly smaller
determinant we've already seen them
without calling them that way so for
example so the matrix of minors will
have again the same size okay let's say
we want this entry then we just delete
this row and this column so this one in
this column and we are left with a 2 by
2 determinant okay so here we'll put the
determinant 4 5 1 2 which is 4 times 2 8
minus 5 3
let's do the next one so for recently I
delete this row and this column I'm left
with 2 5 1 2 determinant will be 2 times
2 minus 5 is negative 1 then minus 2
then I get to the second wall so I get
to this entry
well to find the minor here I will
delete this hole and this column and I'm
left with 3 3 1 2 3 times 2 minus way is
free and we just cheat and give you the
others I mean I think I've shown you
that I can do them okay so okay so let's
just explain the last one again
the last one is 2 so to find a minor
here I delete this column and this fall
and I take this determinant 2 times 4
minus 2 times 3 okay so it's the same
kind of manipulation that we've seen
when we've taken determinants and cross
products okay step 2 we go to another
matrix that's called cofactors so the
cofactors are pretty much the same thing
as the minors except the signs are
slightly different okay so what we do is
we flip signs according to a
checkerboard dynam so
you start with a plus in the upper left
corner and you alternate pluses and
minuses okay so the hole is if there's a
plus somewhere then there's a minus next
to it and below it and then below a
minus or to the right four - there's a
plus okay so that's what it looks inside
three by three so what do I mean by that
so I don't mean you know make this
positive make this negative and so on
that's not what I mean what I mean is if
there's a plus that means leave it alone
okay
we don't do anything to it it has a
minus that means we flip the same okay
so here we'd get well 3 then 1 minus 2
minus 3 1 plus 1 we are good+ is just to
emphasize 3 minus 4 and 2 okay let's
that is pretty easy I mean the only hard
step in terms of calculations is this
one because you have to compute all of
these 2 by 2 determinants
by the way I mean this minus sign here
see it's actually very related to the
way in which when we do a cross product
we have a minus sign for the second
entry okay we're almost done
third step is to transpose so what does
it mean to transpose it means you read
the holes of your matrix and you void by
desse columns or vice versa
okay so let me just say we switch rows
and columns so what do we get well let's
just read it horizontally and write it
vertically we raid 3 1 minus 2 3 1 minus
2 then we wait - 3 1 1 - 3 1 1 then 3 -
4 - 3 - 4 - ok that's pretty easy and
we're almost done the last step so what
we get here is this is the adjoint
matrix so the fourth and last step is to
divide by the determinant of a ok so
here we have to compute the determinant
to Feifei
so determinant of a ok not the
determinant of this guy so 2 5 8 2 4 5 1
1 2 well I'll let you check my
computation I found that it's equal to 3
okay so the final answer is that a
inverse is one third of the matrix we
got there 3 - 3 3 1 1 - 4 - 2 1 - ok
and now so that tells us remember a told
us how to find we use in terms of the
axes this one tells us now how to find
the axes in terms of the use if you
multiply u1 u2 u3 by this you get back
x1 x2 x3 it also tells you how
to solve the linear system a times x
equals something okay that's the end for
today
you